[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] لقد
حققوا نجاحًا كبيرًا خلال العام المقبل
أو على خشبة المسرح المناسبة ، مسلسل صغير أ
[موسيقى]
تكنولوجيا مالية ، تكنولوجيا ، صحة ، تعليم
، تجارة إلكترونية ، تكنولوجيا ، أعلم أننا
[موسيقى]
نقوم بذلك  هي منطقة الشرق الأوسط
وشمال إفريقيا
أه laufey مؤسس arabi
[موسيقى]
تضرر الرجال في الجائحة أفضل تعديل
لتوصيل الطعام والرعاية الصحية
وتكنولوجيا التعليم
[الموسيقى]
في التكنولوجيا مع تعليم الاتصالات
[الموسيقى  ]
في السنوات القادمة
[الموسيقى]
المنطقة بأسرها يمكنك
400 مليون شخص إنها
منطقة جذابة للغاية ككل
يكمل بعضها البعض ليس
سوقًا جذابًا
[موسيقى]
اه ديموغرافيات جذابة للغاية للاقتصاد الكلي
جذابة للغاية إنها منطقة
فيها  الولايات المتحدة ،
يمكن للجميع أن يعرفوا بعضهم البعض أه
أفضل الحدود الحرة هنا من
15 إلى 18 دولة ، لكن آه ، النهاية العالية
ستكون صعبة ولكن
علينا بيع
القيمة الكاملة لكل شيء معًا
عندما يتعين علينا العمل  سويا او معا